Lebanon has become a cash economy it's
the result of a four-year-old financial
crisis brought about by Decades of
mismanagement and Corruption
the banking sector is crippled and the
country is close to bankruptcy it's the
biggest threat that the government and
the country is facing because it is a
very very very dangerous that the entire
economy is a cash economy all the money
is going to the private sector the
solution is only in one place that is to
normalize and finalize the restructuring
of the banking system low
restructuring is one of the reforms
required for much needed international
support to revive the economy but that
means the political and business Elite
will have to compromise their hold on
power something they have resisted so
far
in the meantime money transfer companies
have stepped in as have other financial
institutions many of which are not
regulated
50 to 60 of the total GDP are today
considered to be in the shadow economy
so outside the states
this includes two types of activities
you have
informal activities which means
Enterprises who do not declare the
employees that they have who do not
declare their exact revenues but also
you have the illicit part of these
activities this is causing concern
particularly among Western Nations that
tracking illicit cash transactions will
become more difficult compromising the
fight against money laundering and the
financing of armed groups an estimated
eight billion dollars is exchanging
hands outside the radar of the state
that includes illegal activities such as
smuggling across the border to Syria the
informal economy is also growing the
international labor organization
estimates that 60 percent of the
workforce is not taxed and doesn't
benefit from social protection
the government is unable to provide
services and it struggles to pay public
servants although these salaries are
negligible given inflation
economy means big losses the government
loses around 20 to 25 percent of
expected revenues because of corruption
bribery and tax evasion
all the while many warn Lebanon is
operating outside the International
Financial system
Beirut
and zaina is joining us live from Beirut
now in Lebanon Central Bank is trying to
put a bottom on the Free Fall of the
Lebanese Lira but are its efforts making
any difference zaina
[Music]
has been devaluing over the past four
years since the onset of a financial
crisis in late 2019 since then time and
time again the Central Bank pumps
millions of dollars into the market
hoping to stabilize the exchange rate of
the currency yes it recovers slightly
but at the end of the day it continues
its depreciation and that's why a few
dozen people were gathered outside the
Government Palace here in central Beirut
a short while ago the security forces
lobbed tear gas excessive amounts of
tear gas to disperse the crowd people
here are upset they say that they came
here to demand better living conditions
that they can no longer survive and that
their purchasing power has been eroded
yes there is a portion of the population
here who earn in dollars but there's
also a portion of the population who
earn in the local currency and who are
who are struggling to survive with us is
you've been fighting for the rights of
depositors and the Lebanese people for
four years years now what is your
reaction to what happened today actually
first this is the tears guy tear gas
that our government is shooting on us
okay with these guys are asking for
their rights after several years of
service in the military service they
have their deposits at the bank so even
the the government are are not giving
him their rights even the banks also are
not giving withdrawing their money so
these guys they have the right to do
whatever they have to do even though we
saw some friendly fire so we saw some
soldiers that they are running they are
They Carried that carried them because
they can't they can't breathe anymore so
these guys are firing on the soldiers in
between the people and the security of
the Government Palace yes but we've seen
protests like this over the past four
years and to no avail nothing changes
why
because most of the politicians they
don't have ears to hear because they
don't want to act accordingly because
they are not serious in solving the
problem most of most of the rights there
are it's on it's non-discussable you
know you it's you don't need anyone to
explain these rights but they don't even
in the parliament they didn't try even
to find to find because they they are
they are protecting their own interests
because none of the parliamentors or the
the ministers or the PM are not acting
in a serious way especially for the
depositors goes because as we saw as you
know that the capital control we've been
waiting for it for three years we didn't
see any Capital control any plan for the
to solve the problem right until now
fairuz can you tell us what daily life
is like for the average Lebanese today
with disaster who are living in a
disaster we are withdrawing our money
and for fifteen thousand liras and the
lira is around 120 120 it reached the
150 140 yesterday and now it decreased
to 120 this is a this is a game actually
in uh the rate of the Lira and we cannot
we cannot spend we cannot pay our
electricity it's becoming in dollars
actually kind of in dollars and we are
withdrawing our money for 15 000. for us
thank you very much so as you can see
the economy is becoming dollarized not
everybody has access to Dollars people's
savings are trapped in Banks they take
to the streets to ask for better living
conditions and the response is
um tear gas and this is something we've
seen for four years the response from
the state has been militarized
zaina thank you very much for that that
is Zana joining us live from Beirut
thank you